- Songwriting is about your experiences,
and it expands your vocabulary
in terms of the way you see the world.
Music is something that
people can connect with
and feel an emotion.
There was a few really
cool underground spots
where I would go and
listen to jazz in Dubai
and I'd see all these musicians
and I'd be like yeah
that's where I wanna be at.
- I'm Anna Devis.
- I am Daniel Rueda.
- Together, we are
architects and photographers.
- [Daniel] Our approach is
to play with perspectives
and geometry within an urban landscape.
- [Anna] And as architects,
we travel the world
exploring and seeing aspects of buildings
so we can tell stories through the image.
- [Daniel] We are on a
journey to meet with other
like-minded and inspiring
creatives in Dubai.
- [Anna] Here, we meet with Layla Kardan,
a bold new performer who is
breaking perceptions of what
it means to be a female
singer in the Middle East.
- [Daniel] We first meet Layla in Dubai's
old neighborhood of Al Fahidi.
(traditional oud music)
- I think, both of you being architects,
you can appreciate that
it's such a completely
different architecture to what
you typically see in Dubai.
- Yeah.
- [Daniel] Yeah, not many
skyscrapers around here.
- We were living in
Australia and my father
was really excited about
the great opportunity
in Dubai, so he moved us here.
It was such a different
world to what I'd seen,
you know, growing up in
Sydney, but it became,
you know, a home for us.
I have really beautiful
memories as a child
growing up in Dubai and got to learn a lot
about the culture.
You really feel the
history and the heritage
of the people when you come to the creek.
Really interesting
alleyways in these bazaars
where you'll see spice
markets, fabric merchants,
sellers of antique jewelry,
and all of that is a feast for the eyes.
I like to reference traditional
Middle Eastern instruments,
just because I love the sounds of them.
But in a subtle way, I like
the oud more as a drum beat,
and warp it and distort
it, but it's still there.
- It's a very clever way to make a very
historical instrument not
too lost in the history
and use it in a more contemporary way.
I think it's fascinating, actually.
(slow piano chords)
- [Anna] Even though you feel
you are in such a modern city,
you know you are in Dubai,
you are not in America
or in Europe because they always have this
traditional touch in everything they do.
- [Daniel] At night, the
whole city comes to life
and we begin to understand
how Dubai's music scene
has become a crucial part
of the nightlife here.
- [Layla] In the last three years,
there's live music all over town.
Before we would go to this
one spot to watch Jazz music,
and now you can, in one
night, I can name like seven
or eight or even more places.
♪ Yeah yeah yeah yeah ♪
- [Anna] Wanting to share a more intimate
side to the music scene,
Layla invites us to an after party,
where we meet the community of musicians
that she collaborates with.
- Guys, this is a complete jam,
so we don't even know
what we're doing, sorry.
And that's another thing
I love about Dubai,
is that I've got an
incredible band of musicians
from all over the world.
(upbeat jazz music)
Wherever you go in the world,
it's important to see the
culture and the music.
♪ Guilded ♪
♪ I wanted it golden ♪
I think it's the first thing
that teaches us tolerance is
when you understand a little
bit about a person's culture
and where they're from.
Music is a very beautiful
way to share a message.
♪ No place to go ♪
- [Anna] This day with Layla
has given us opportunity
to see Dubai's strong artistic circle.
Allowing inspiration and
vision among musicians
to be shared through collaboration.
♪ No place to go ♪
- An experience we won't
forget in a music scene
we were unaware of before coming.
Yes, sir!
(light guitar solo)